für dieses video sind ergebnissen auf
die spur gekommen
wir haben gefälschte
pflanzenschutzmittel getauft wird
wirklich profit gemacht auf basis der
gesundheit und unsere umwelt
unser verdacht von illegalen laboren in
der ukraine über polen gelangt zum
beispiel gefälschtes glyphosat nach
deutschland auf deutschen feldern und
damit vielleicht in deine nahrung
wir haben es also hier mit kriminellen
zu tun
wir machen uns auf die spur der
gefälschten pestizide nach osteuropa und
sprechen mit informanten die die
kriminellen machenschaften gut kennen
nachfrage schafft angebote nur weil es
in der eu eine nachfrage nach dem zeug
machen dass hier die leute trotz groß
angelegten razzien stellen die
ermittlungsbehörden nur einen bruchteil
sicher wir wollen herausfinden wie
einfach ist der handel mit illegalen
chemikalien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
80.000 tonnen pestizide werden jedes
jahr in deutschland gekauft von
kleingärtnern bauern und agrar
großbetrieben diese pestizide landen
also früher oder später auf den
deutschen feldern und böden und
rückstände davon in deinem essen
das allein ist schon besorgniserregend
doch der eigentliche skandal ist gut 15
prozent davon sind gefälscht und gelang
illegal nach deutschland
von diesen pflanzen giften geht ein noch
höheres risiko für umwelt und mensch aus
ohne jede prüfung unsere spurensuche
beginnt im labor des bundesamtes für
verbraucherschutz und
lebensmittelsicherheit in braunschweig
hier analysieren spezialisten gefälschte
pestizide
gerade wird wieder eine verdachts probe
untersucht sie wird in ein lösungsmittel
gegeben
dort löst sich das pestizid aber nicht
auf auch nicht nach 24 stunden müsste es
aber diese probe es nicht in ordnung
dieses pflanzenschutzmittel dürfte so
nicht angewendet
chemiker nils coleman zeigt uns zwei
produkte die der brandenburgische zoll
beschlagnahmt und ans bundesamt
geschickt hat glyphosat steht drauf was
aber drin ist weiß keiner
diese pflanzenschutzmittel sind illegal
sie sind nirgendwo zugelassen diese
angebliche firmenname hier ist frei
erfunden
am grab all das gibt es gar nicht das
ist keine firma die pflanzenschutzmittel
legal in verkehr bringen darf immerhin
das angebliche glyphosat hat eine
zulassungsnummer aber das heißt nichts
wer auch immer dieses mittel in verkehr
gebracht hat hat sich irgendeine nummer
für ein völlig anderes
pflanzenschutzmittel willkürlich
ausgewählt und erweckt hier den eindruck
es sei an vom bundesamt für
verbraucherschutz und
lebensmittelsicherheit zugelassenes
mittel aber das ist es nicht
wir haben es also hier mit kriminellen
zu tun im netz werden sie angeboten die
illegalen stoffe zum beispiel auf der
seite landhandel - polen de der händler
wendet sich an deutsche kunden und gibt
ein versprechen wir liefern ihnen alle
produkte auch ohne sachkundenachweis das
ist illegal
denn in deutschland gilt wer beruflich
pestizide anwendet oder verkauft braucht
laut gesetz einen sachkundenachweis er
soll einen sicheren umgang mit
giftstoffen garantieren
auch muss sich jeder sachkundige alle
drei jahre fortbilden und den nachweis
erneuern
wir schauen uns auf der seite um und
finden auch glyphosat von agrar bohle
dasselbe gefälschte produkt das uns im
labor gezeigt wurde
die seite wirbt außerdem wir liefern
auch produkte die in deutschland nicht
mehr zugelassen sind und tatsächlich
landhandel - polen de bietet zahlreiche
wirkstoffe an die in der eu verboten
sind die kriminellen händler fühlen sich
ziemlich sicher ermittlern ist es
bislang nicht gelungen diese
internetseite sperren zu lassen denn die
server sind außerhalb der eu
wir bestellen das pestizid von agrar
bulle und warten ob es uns wirklich
geliefert wird doch was ist eigentlich
ein pestizid genau
es besteht aus mehreren komponenten
basis ist der chemische wirkstoff der
schädlinge und unkraut abtöten soll er
zu kommen bei stoffe wie lösungsmittel
emulatoren oder farbstoffe
diese dienen dazu dass das pestizid von
der pflanze besser aufgenommen wird bis
ein mittel zugelassen wird muss es
zahlreiche teure überprüfung bestehen
genau diesen schritt sparen sich die
fälscher gewinnmargen sind sehr hoch
denn dieses zulassungsverfahren ist
umfangreich das kostet die firmen viel
geld bis sie so ein pflanzenschutzmittel
erstmals auf den markt bringen dürfen
die reinen produktionskosten sind sehr
niedrig vielleicht wenige prozent der
gesamtkosten und deshalb können sie als
fälscher sehr sehr viel geld verdienen
nach zwei tagen erhalten wir tatsächlich
eine lieferung aus polen so einfach
bekommen die in deutschland ein
gefälschtes pestizid ausgerechnet
glyphosat
es steht im verdacht krebserregend zu
sein und wer weiß was für ein gift hier
tatsächlich drin ist
die zulassungsnummer ist identisch mit
dem kanister die uns im labor gezeigt
wurde
wir finden heraus die zulassungsnummer
gibt es tatsächlich
sie findet sich auf der liste der
zugelassenen pflanzenschutzmittel in
deutschland stand oktober 2020 die 0 0
61 73 6 2 gehört aber einem ganz anderen
produkt klinik great das ist zugelassen
glyphosat von agra pole aber nicht die
zulassungsnummer hat der fälscher also
einfach gestohlen
wir wollen wissen wer steckt hinter der
internetseite
im impressum werden zwei adressen
genannt eine im deutschen kugeln und
eine im polnischen greifenberg wir
fahren hin
beide adressen erweisen sich als fake
weder in greifenberg noch hier in guben
treffen wir unter der angegebenen
adresse jemanden an landhandel - polen
de gibt es hier nicht der oder die
betreiber verstecken sich aus gutem
grund das landeskriminalamt brandenburg
ermittelt
auch europol fahndet verstärkt nach
illegalen pestiziden vor allem in den
seehafen europas immer wieder stellen
ermittler pestizide sicher die entweder
gar nicht oder falsch etikettiert sind
das was eigentlich schlimm daran ist
dass es sich hier nicht nur um
produktpiraterie handelt es geht sind
jetzt keine ton schuhe oder handtaschen
sondern pestizide haben natürlich einen
einfluss auf den menschen und auch auf
die auf die umgebung auf die umwelt das
heißt hier wird wirklich profit gemacht
auf basis der gesundheit und
umwelt seit fünf jahren fahndet europol
mit der operation silva ex jeweils im
frühjahr nach illegalen pestiziden 2015
suchte europol die pestizid panzer in
sieben ländern 2020 waren es bereits 32
länder weltweit und die menge an
sichergestellten fälschungen wuchs von
190 tonnen im jahr 2015 auf 1.346 tonnen
in diesem jahr
wenn sie ein land haben wo regularien
zurückgeschraubt werden oder wo
kontrollen zurückgeschraubt werden das
dauert nicht lange bis kriminelle
strukturen das erkannt haben es geht
einfach darum wo kann man aus einer
einer sicheren basis heraus ein produkt
in den markt schieben wo man dafür dann
viel geld dafür bekommt unser
gefälschtes glyphosat kommt aus polen
hergestellt werden solche fälschungen
häufig in der ukraine
wir bekommen ein hinweis von europol und
fahren in den süden des landes labor
besser
der ukrainische staat ist geschwächt
durch den krieg im osten des landes in
der landwirtschaft und bei pestiziden
kontrollieren behörden kaum noch
so fallen auch ukrainische bauern auf
kriminelle reihen die pestizide fashion
was sie diese rocker brauchte ein mittel
gegen den pilzbefall seiner kulturen und
wollte geld sparen das bereute heute ich
habe wahrscheinlich zu billig gekauft
schon beim auspacken sah ich die
aufkleber waren schief ich rief den
händler an der meint alles in ordnung
das ist ein gutes mittel
ich habe ihm geglaubt weil ich ihn schon
länger kenne aber dann hat sich
herausgestellt dass es doch
irgendwelcher schrott war nach 34 tagen
wurden die pflanzen weiß und das war's
odessa ist der größte hafen des landes
nach erkenntnissen der ermittler
hauptumschlagplatz für illegale
pestizide darüber reden will niemand
erst nach wochenlangen recherchen finden
wir dann doch ein zeugen
ein spediteur der das geschäft mit den
illegalen pestiziden kennt er will nicht
erkannt werden nicht mal seine stimme
soll zu hören sein
nachfrage schafft angebote nur weil es
in der eu eine nachfrage nach dem zeug
gibt machen dass hier die leute die
ukraine ist sehr arm und natürlich
werden solche chancen ergriffen und es
ist ziemlich simpel man kann pestizide
um label mit einem anderen code versehen
es beim zoll anders deklarieren
so kann es problemlos nach polen
gebracht werden und ein weiterer trick
ist man gründet eine firma immer nur für
eine ladung und dann ist man weg und
werden diese händler doch einmal
geschnappt drohen ihnen keine harten
strafen seit 2011 gab es gerade mal elf
strafanzeigen zu strafrechtlichen
verurteilungen kam es noch nie dabei
wird hier grob fahrlässig mit unserer
gesundheit gespielt denn keiner weiß wo
gefälschte pestizide angewendet und
somit mensch und natur durch illegale
gifte gefährdet werden
wie seht ihr den einsatz von pestiziden
legalen und illegalen schreibt es uns in
die kommentare